[Music]
halloween
it's ice time
yeah i thought you could get a head
start on heist prep good luck
i'm already dressed well
i am also dressed and i made breakfast
wait where are my eggs in my belly
yeah now get a move on it's heist time i
love halloween
sorry sarge
ugh halloween is the worst
everyone's drunk wearing a mask and
carrying a fake gun
plus all the girls think they have to
dress sexy i know that is the worst
please make them stop i passed a [ __ ]
tree on the way here who wants to have
sex with a tree was it a maple was it a
maple
bonjourno bonjourno pretty cool stewm
huh stem short for costume ah all right
let me guess you are dumpy chuck norris
no don't be ron weasley no guys stop it
he put thought into his costume and he
is obviously miranda from sex in the
city guys i'm mario batali malto mario
celebrity chef ginger prince of little
italy is he also a homeless troll doll
cause you look like a homeless troll dog
hey sweet batali costume dude thank you
there is a man with impeccable taste he
bit a guy's butt off at a wnba game
eric stultz from mask i'll take it
good morning boyle it's halloween
i'm surprised you didn't put on a
costume i was going to sir but then i
decided
screw that jazz
well i'm the only one who ever dresses
up no one ever gets my costume and they
make fun of me so i'm done
these people don't deserve my dress-up
gifts
charles
seriously no costume what the hell
charles where's your halloween spirit
but you guys always make fun of me i
have never once insulted you in my life
especially vis-a-vis your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and or thing yes i do remember
sir permission to sprint to my car and
get my emergency costume does it matter
if i say no no
[Music]
ba bam bam boom
what the what why are you dressed up you
look like an idiot but
yeah what are you supposed to be a sassy
car mechanic no come on he's clearly the
rejected pop-tarts mascot harry pop-tart
i am not you know who i am squad that's
enough you're making boyle football on
purpose he's elvis yes elvis stoico the
canadian figure skater no
okay parties around the corner tipster
said there will be a huge amount of drug
activity
why is this costume so stiff and what is
that smell the department never washes
them so let's probably vomit hey
i got you a chocolate yet another great
thing about halloween chocolate thanks
oh look raggedy ann is drinking vodka
right from the bottle people think if
they put on a costume they can just get
away with anything they want
halloween is christmas for jerks
come on ma'am no open containers um why
should i listen to you bone person it's
called a skeleton it's a very common
word just put the vodka away
you guys are cops these guys are cops
attention boys and ghouls nope every
halloween i dress up in an amazing
costume and you never get what i am no
we get what you are an adult man who
enjoys dress-up very funny rosa this
year that won't be a problem because
you're gonna pick my costume oh come on
uh
ms pacman's nipple no that's brown why
would you know that to be on not to be
not to be thank you
joan of arc rod stewart martha stewart
he-man master of the universe i got it
gay robin hood
oh my gosh that's what it is
come on amy who's enough you look like
such a cop come on have some fun you
know
to help you blend in
stop trying to get me to love halloween
it'll never work i'm backing it up oh
god please don't
hey
heads up
i'll cut him off at the exit okay
he ditched the drugs i'm on it
oh everything is sticking to me oh
okay
yeah you're watching man
what is that
how is it hot and cold
handmaid's tale this is amy she won't
shut up about how relevant that show is
in today's political landscape it's
relevant as hell but i'm not doing
anything
terry also loved the show this is him no
no i love elizabeth moss terry thought
the show was too bleak oh they're coming
from everywhere hello blessed be the
fruit baby fish [ __ ] you watch that show
watch what that's my pickup line what
are they doing i haven't heard from
charles we need to check to make sure
everything check what the server i stole
the cummerbund from under there an hour
ago you knew about you playing the
server i've known about your plans for
weeks uh oh they're circling stop
hello
of amy
who
[Music]
i don't know what's going on i do
handmaid's out
hey really listen to you
what is all this
no i think halloween is for jerks well
this halloween i was the jerk
i'm sorry about tonight
i'm sorry about tonight we found the
title for santiago's follow-up sex tape
i'm sorry i couldn't convince you to
love halloween it's not your fault i was
terrible it's not your fault i was
terrible it's also one of your sex tapes
halloween is unbearable but
it was slightly less unbearable with you
don't okay
anyway we're all going to the bar so get
changed cause you can't be the only one
there not wearing a stome stim oh my god
caught on no no
you betrayed me but why i can't have
more of these trophies in our home the
cummerbund was already in the living
room what's next a rusty medical
bracelet suspended above our bed yes now
hand it over i don't have it i gave it
to amy santiago you betrayed me as well
you betrayed me first you were working
with rosa this whole time that wasn't
real i was always gonna stab her in the
back you were what kind of person treats
another human being like that you
dropped me rosa and then you shipped me
to new jersey first of all grow up
second of all how'd you get back here so
fat if you get a box wet enough it's
very easy to bust out of it no one asked
any follow-ups i knew i couldn't trust
you rosa that's what i was gonna
double-cross you with bill that's right
he didn't really die hey guys you really
thought i'd miss this year's heist no
way i'm part of the squad wrong okay
this is officially getting too hard to
track who has the bracelet now santiago
yeah and none of you are getting it
we'll see about that
what the hell remember that very fancy
swiss pen i got you for christmas the
one that you keep in your pocket at all
times it's a taser bro
yeah i'll take that amy do not make me
taste you again no no don't i'm pregnant
what i just found out it's a girl oh my
god oh my god it's happening quick
someone get a reaction video of me
becoming an uncle ah she's making it up
the pregnancy scan was my idea no no no
no no amy wait is that true did you just
lie to me about our baby yeah did you
lie to us about our baby you taste me
you chased me first uh
salutations captain
i was wondering perchance if you would
like to attend the opera with me this
eve i'll pass choosing instead to stay
in my locked office with my watch still
safely on my wrist
i had a feeling you might say that thus
far i've decided to bring the opera to
you
hitchcock scully
no need for the somersaults disagreed
all monitor now block his path
okay boyle and only because you insisted
i say this it's time to drop a deuce
[Music]
whoa come on amy not cool that's a guy
peralta that's enough
you